[Music]
what's up guys calling for the score
eSports here back at you with our second
ever tech in top 10 now sorry it took so
long to make this video but I was thrown
off a volcano at the end of our last one
good news though it turns out I'm 180th
Mishima and I have the devil gene who'da
thought now our last video was of course
the top 10 Tekken 7 comeback rounds but
as we all know a single round does not
tell the story of an entire match and
comeback starts when you've fallen
behind but as an underdog the odds are
stacked against you from the very
beginning hey who is the roadway anyways
who is this guy he's all a player huh
yeah [ __ ] as an underdog you face an
uphill battle before the match even
starts these are the tales of those
underdogs who overcame the odds those
Davids who beat their goliaths to earn
glory for themselves their character and
in some cases their country so without
further ado here are the top ten Tekken
7 underdog moments kicking off this list
his gob fury and his incredible win over
the legendary JDC are at combo breaker
2018 against the Koreans dragon off joey
decided to go full american and
proceeded to dominate the match with
paul phoenix gotcha coffee
10 seconds you got to leave
zero look at that face look at that race
this is beatdown oh this if it's true or
it's not it's a little high and down one
no well Brown bro for round straight on
JD CRI slowly tighten it up now cool now
you pitch the lead very slow when he's
got the rayji though let's go over
dangerous but now look at all he's funny
he's about a loose Laird 23 but take out
Jaden CR JD's got the rangy though he's
got the way to one death I said it's
over oh good - break time to the wall
now my god
[Applause]
JD's dr oh man Wow our number nine entry
comes courtesy of dojin at rage art 2017
after barely missing out on a trip to
the king of the Iron Fist tournament in
2016 dojin found himself up against the
reigning champion st. with the support
of the hometown crowd the Filipino
player defied the odds and eliminated
the Korean superstar for a chance to
represent his country in the
tournament's grand final
okay those are making a statement but
it's see it ready for the race he was
waiting for that
oh that's good benchmark for PvE doujin
it goes the strength or the precious
real rodeo just to get away
rage drive safe
Wow whoa dude please achieve me firmly
to do something coming in at number
eight is geese masters faded match
against no be from Evo 2016 with
previous wins at Evo and the king of the
Iron Fist tournament Nobby had already
proven his dominance at Tekken 7 and it
seemed unlikely that geese master would
even take around in this set things
you're gonna see you I mean things are
gonna work out for him I guarantee he's
gonna get around he's gonna do better
than me kick a little bit against na
rock a little bit you see to get around
an OB okay which is which is really rare
anything I mean trust me a lot of people
do not get around a note but with the
support of the hometown crowd
the Americans unorthodox bang helped
secure an incredible upset victory over
the former champion ray Jones is scary
oh look at this G snap to get some the
Boer is my checkbook nice decent punch
there oh oh my sidewalk final round
coming up geeks master against Nobby
Yogi's meant to be hugely to the Walshes
buddies confidence nobody's in trouble
he's been training it was part day what
he does USA on the scoreboard holy boy I
said he's gonna get around this guy got
a game drag enough with the range very
scary care Mikey I like it said nose got
to be careful he's way behind this round
Aggies faster one round away oh my god
meeting Nova from Japan
great stop there put the friction
eliminate no me while the crowd is going
crazy nobody goes home with 50 plays I
feel like I should give you more money
for that into the wardrobe the number 7
spot on our list is Tarun Khanna take
down Saint at Beast arena Hong Kong 2018
now it goes without saying but we're
just gonna say it anyways Saint is an
incredible player with more titles under
his belt than we can even count
so when Tonto Khanna eliminated him from
the tournament she couldn't help but let
her a pop off so pure you think she'd
just won the entire thing moving star
tonic all the healthy lead here but
saint has made some crazy comebacks on
this time beautiful with punished and
now final round Saints are you all right
buddy whoa yeah beautiful combo there
from counter Cana she's taking Game one
oh you guys should look at the crowd
right now everyone is just watching
whether tunnel Connect will be able to
make this upsell back turn gets a throw
no break one more I'll do it there it is
yeah Saint just stays on the ground
right there med lab match point the
upset I think this will be an upset
there's a race drive another mix-up
coming Oh slap she pops off she stands
up she is popping off but a scramble
there at the end she is screaming out I
did it I did it I did it in st. your NCR
champion that's a big win for her that's
a huge win the number six spot on our
list goes to team cuddle core for their
victory against team Anakin at a
league's second team to take down team
Anakin was stacked with some of the best
players na has to offer and many thought
that Jimmy J Tran would be team cuddle
Coors only hope of pulling off a win but
instead it was cuddle core herself who
closed out the final match to earn her
squad a spot in the grand final where
they go on to win the whole thing
remember way back at the start of the
tournament Anakin said one of the people
he really rated home was a little bit
fitfully plan was cuddle coffee oh right
dude this patients from joy if you throw
break kills two rounds of these this is
where the nerves are so important can't
Joey stay solid jumps over the D book no
blocks range and that's a quick rounds
joy drew he's gonna need to calm down
he's gonna need those nerves of steel if
you really want to continue on that's
safe no more
she takes out Joey Fury
no these cuddles do they started out oh
my god now that becomes something worse
team mannequin need to remember what the
safety word is to be careful
puts our team in the grand finals
without Jimmy J track even to play at
the halfway point on our list is books
unbelievable win on home soil at Tiger
uppercut 2018 after a brutal beatdown
from me in the winner's final book took
out John ding in convincing fashion for
a chance at revenge in the grand final
and with the hometown crowd on his side
our Thai hero was able to reset the
bracket and close out the series with a
solid 302 one now book good stuff do not
anger need do not anger me brother Bruce
come
uh-uh Oh give it a lay low and book
resets it nee naughty what you learn
Ellen to compute dad oh boy one month
once a burger I forgot 2018 for book
you're only setting the bracket against
me go to your lectric block rookie snow
patient that's it downpour takes it who
is your champion
hey the crowd erupts I can't believe it
he can't believe it
[Applause]
coming in at the fourth spot on our list
is no Roma's breakout performance at
Tekken World Tour Korea 2017 nowadays no
Roma needs no introduction but that
wasn't the case just two years ago the
Roma at the time wasn't so
internationally well known like right
people who like for kind of watching
tacking up until that point they kind of
it was a name that they knew but for a
young player especially from a region in
Japan that does not have that much
representation on a major stage to come
to Korea and shock everybody by winning
the thing there that's crazy that's
unheard of in fact it wasn't until he
took out some of the best Korean players
in Korea that the Japanese player made a
name for himself as one of the best
Tekken players in the world
hey who is the row by anyways who is
this guy he's all I'm playing for huh
yeah [ __ ] wants you to do after big boom
again
the same situation we saw the previous
round so is this gonna be a trouble
purple cows about the shale but that's
the first match I forgot that that was
the first match the first match goes to
neuroma all the big hit and aroma is up
two to one each is on the verge the
momentum looking to rent him and yet
sham for two he let him walk down guy
hit somebody does he play online what I
need an APB the wall Oh funny case y'all
what sure about that down lazy all what
a god fish is eating at the back to yes
to stop the other way arms the longer
arms
no pun is that all the back to this is
big no Romo might be able to take it
here oh the pressure he has a mere eight
one where he could do it oh my god oh my
god oh my god there's no way yo JD
Seahawk are you a god only a real master
oh the big debugger that's gonna be it
no Romo is our champion here
in Korea winning it for Japan can you
believe that taking the third spot on
our list is little Majan and his
absolutely epic run at evo 2018 having
already taken out the likes of neuroma
and John ding America's fan favorite
tore his way through the top eight but
still found himself as the underdog
against JD CR in the winner's
semi-finals I don't think so I don't
know but either way you know he'd be a
fool to bet against him no matter what's
the situation
yeah matter what probably one of the
most consistent consistent second player
yes also a former Evo champion as well
but in what ended up being one of the
most exciting matches of the year the
king player put on a performance that
won't soon be forgotten
no GTR he's a story champion that fell
ill Majin he's rarely had opportunities
to shine out these big stages but he is
definitely bringing oh here we go off
the heads he wants to hear the crowd wow
he looks so determined the USA chants in
the ground oh here's a chance for now is
he going yeah downstairs we should be
able to get the follow but this order
was wrong oh he went for the heart tall
oh my god he's gonna do it he got the
round
I'm Leo Scorpio I can feel it in my
loins oh boy you got him to the powder
sugar Motta visible gypsum is helping
out picked up JD's here might not be
able to retaliate no no gin oh my gosh
he still gets three I'll take this right
back up to a reverse sweep this isn't
gonna work we're gonna need to get a
stunt double in here
I need a stunt double in here
I love this guy we might possibly see it
oh gosh
there goes limit scaling the damage here
comes the corkscrew the world
tournaments let's go Martin gets it one
more he could do it oh my gosh
Paris I can't believe what I'm seeing
guys can I get a break any chance I know
we wanted to take a break any chance we
could get a gurney I'm gonna need some
help I need more water - guys this is an
emergency did you watch that did you see
that the runner-up spot on our list goes
to rank you for doing the impossible at
the Tekken world - or 2018 finals in
fact this moment was so incredible we
made a whole separate video about it not
only was ranked to a heavy underdog but
his character was - you know in the
history of Tekken there has never been a
bear champion there has never met been a
low tier character winning the global
tournament M no one expected a panda to
be the world champion be careful of one
more you get in here
[Applause]
champion here Bersani sports rock - nice
work our second one Tour champion not
even Tekken's very own producer panda
father taking the top spot for Tekken 7
underdog moment is none other than our
Celyn ashes run at Evo Japan 2019
forgetting the fact that he came from an
underestimated country Arslan almost
didn't even make it to Evo Japan and we
have a separate video dedicated to
telling that specific story now this is
so phase 2
he has a hard time even making evil
Japan right Victor 9 and fees are the
first I know yeah but thank goodness he
did make it because after dropping to
the losers side the Pakistanis kazumi
proved to be absolutely unstoppable
he's got the pork back okay the moment
of truth here his chair very big who's
gonna have what it takes to be know is
going to the grand finals to play
against ATK oh my god I was good what a
win footage Eddy gets the wall here one
thing some can do it right here
and that will be another three around
eight bars and he's up to two one one
more game oh my god
the Phoenix oh I liked what he was doing
but man too hard it was ready pushing
him towards the danger zone
champion Pakistan taking the tournament
over the Philippines this weekend's a
tank and star was born and his name is
Arslan - well guys that was our list
this time now if you want to take a
deeper dive into Tekken 7 check out our
videos on our Celyn Ashe and ranches
stories I highly recommend them and if
you want more tech and content in the
future comment below and let us know
what you want us to do you know Normie
Colin was pretty low-tier an underdog if
you will but now that I possess the
devil gene I can finally fulfill my
destiny and become king of the iron
mustache thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages